here he is on the mercedes-benz vans
phone line because i didn't spend enough
time with him over a 90-hour period he
always has me at hello like football on
a stick he is the co-host the move that
sticks podcast and one of the best in
the business
analyzing what's going on right now
daniel jeremiah how are you dj
i'm doing great rich i i i got to tell
you a quick story which you appreciate
so you kind of have this long week and
then uh i'm home last night i got
delayed i had to connect in phoenix oh
so i was late getting out of indy so i
got stuck in phoenix for a while so i
didn't get home to like five but it's
like eight o'clock at night
and uh i get this weird i'm like you
know what i just need to i need a q-tip
so i gotta get youtube just kind of
clean out the year so i start it's eight
o'clock i start walking towards our
master bedroom and i see my daughter's
bedroom who's off at college and that
bed
was like something that just completely
sucked me in that i could not make it
down the rest of the hallway at eight
o'clock i flop on top of my daughter's
bed next to me you know it's 5 30 in the
morning i hear you
by the way uh my flight landed at 8 40
in the morning i was in this chair by 9
am doing this show
i don't know how i got through yesterday
because this is it's a lot man i know
we're just sitting on our behinds just
watching guys run around cones
technically
but it is a lot there's just a lot going
on and you're so great at it man you
make it easy for me and everybody else
and it's just awesome it really wasn't
it's fun
it's a blast it it's a it really is a
blast and you get to do with you and we
we would always joke on our walks back
that yes um you know we're trying to
make each other laugh as we're because
we're going through these long days
those are some of my favorite moments of
the week
they certainly are me too man um now
that we're through it uh a good uh 48
almost removed from the final drill
who do you think's number one overall
what's the sense as you walk out of the
combine who who's going to be the first
name read by roger goodell
in vegas coming up what do you think i i
think you know look we're just we got a
long ways to go but just kind of what
you hear and uh just kind of looking at
it from the outside i i think it's
pointing towards your guy aidan
hutchinson being the first overall pick
really i just think he's
i think he's too clean he's too safe
this is a jaguar team that um
let's just say they haven't been
rewarded for going outside the box in
recent history so i would think that
just put this thing right in the fairway
that's aidan hutchinson he's you know
it's insulting to say that he's kind of
a a high floor player because i feel
like you sell him short a little bit and
he can't be an elite player i think he
can be um so you the the makeup the
production
you know the height weight speed i don't
care you know people look at the 40
nobody cares about the 40 with edge
rushers his 10 time was excellent his
three cone was i think the best of the
entire group which is all the the stuff
that translates to pass rush so um to me
you're the jacksonville jaguars you need
to get this one right and i just think
that aiden hutchinson is just again
parking this thing right out in the
middle of the fairway well that three
cone drill from what i heard too was
similar to that of a slot receiver that
that's how fast he is i think there were
only like only like two or three
receivers in this draft that had a
better three-pound time so
yeah that's that's pretty special and
again that's those are just three cones
set up on the uh on the turf and you run
it around it a certain way and you're
timed and that's how you can be
um measured for your explosiveness and
things like that correct that's just
something
people understand direction yeah
explosiveness the three cone is really
great for pass rushers because you see
the explosiveness you see the change of
direction and you see the ability to
bend kind of when you come around that
last cone so those are pretty important
the characteristics of pass rushers so
um yeah he was great there well i guess
if we if i i just got that one out of
you we could kind of mock it in a way so
if that happens then the lions would
take who would that open the door for
kyle hamilton a safety to go to would
they need a pass protector for whoever
if god goff or whoever they they go
long term at that position what would
the lions do it too
what would they do i would say i would
say offensive line would be out rich
just because you know they're in pretty
good shape there especially with penne
sewell who they took last year right um
so i i would cross the tackles off the
list you bring up kyle hamilton um you
know people are split on that of how
early do you take a safety right i i
honestly think and i you know i think
kavon thibodeau comes into play there um
as an edge rusher and we talked about it
during the broadcast would not shock me
at all if trayvon walker climbed all the
way up to the second pick in this draft
i mean he's
he's just such a he's a unique
player i mean you don't see guys with
that height weight speed combination
with the fluidity that he showed
and you know the knock on him people
said oh you know
kind of had average sack production and
you can't take a guy all the way up
there and then all you have to do is
point to jermaine johnson who was
playing in that same georgia defense had
four sacks um and then he goes to
florida state because he wanted to
actually get on the field consistently
and he leads the acc at sacks and has 12
and then he goes to the senior bowl and
nobody could block him so
that georgia defense as we've talked
about all week was just absolutely
stacked and loaded um and i think that
that that's like a defensive line
coach's dream to have that combination
of skills that he possesses so i think
he enters the conversation right there
at number two especially if hutchinson
goes one
daniel jeremiah here on the rich eisen
show so you just mentioned that trayvon
walker could go as high as two he he was
so terrific um at the combine and then
you mentioned kayvon thibodeaux could go
there
as well
um
well because i discussed yesterday what
the conversation was coming out of
thibodeau's
40 and then nothing else is that you
know he didn't hurt himself but he also
did not help himself like there's a
difference between you hurt yourself the
combine but you also didn't help
yourself how did how did everything land
again after all the
the dust is now settled with thibodeaux
not working out at the combine
where into which he arrived with so many
questions about his want to motor desire
based on his tape and everything else
daniel yeah i think that the the issue
isn't that he didn't do the field
workout i think if he came into the
combine and did media and talked with
teams and said hey
here's the plan as as a bunch of guys
before him and a bunch of guys after him
will have said which would be
you know either i'm you know i'm going
to go out here i'm just going to run the
40 i've been training for the 40 i'm
going to run the 40 here and then i want
to go do the field workout at oregon and
we've heard guys say it rich right we
want to i want to try and bring as many
scouts as i can to oregon because then
they can get a chance to evaluate my
teammates
it's a great opportunity for them or
even if you didn't say that just said
hey this is my plan i'm going to run the
40 and then i'm going to i'm going to
really hone in on the position drills at
the uh the pro day okay cool no problem
been done a million times nobody would
bat an eye
but when you tell everybody in the media
and with the teams that you plan on
doing everything and then you get out
there and you run a 40 and then you stop
and say i'm done for the day
it was just kind of weird and then the
explanation if his explanation would
have been hey i just want to save
everything for my my pro day
okay i i get it you made a last-second
decision no you know no big deal
but when he said i'd i want to do
linebacker drills well yeah so so does
trayvon walker and so did so do all
these guys and uh they all you get a
chance to do all the linebacker drills
do the d-line drills then you do the
linebacker drills so that the
explanation was just kind of goofy um
and and then you kind of add into that
just kind of coming into the process
um you know
teams kind of have some some concerns
there and i i mentioned it just when you
watch some of the games you see him take
some plays off now it's not like he's
not a he's not a dog right somebody just
doesn't play hard all the time oh he
just there's some plays here there
and uh and that was just a little bit of
a concern so you come here you do
everything you put that all to bed and
we move on but he chose not to do that
so
in a year where
you know we're a little bit uh light at
that position and probably it wouldn't
be you know a big deal either but we're
so stacked at that position i think he
gave up some room for those guys to
leapfrog him and yet though you still
think it's possible he could go to
overall if hutchinson goes one overall
and that's the way the dominoes tumble
when all comes down no i think that's i
i think that's entirely possible so i
mean this thing could all come out in
the washing and he's the second pick
overall and it was much ado about
nothing but i i can't i agree with the
way you phrased it he just kind of
opened the door a little bit to uh to
give those other guys some room to jump
in or on the other hand if it's apples
to apples as you and a bunch of other uh
um you know evaluators like to say where
it's just like okay we want to pass
rusher and i can go with trayvon walker
of georgia or kayvon thibodeau of oregon
this is the this is the measurement or
evaluation that could wind up with the
bulldog being selected right like that's
the way it goes
if you ask me right now yes march 8th
yes sir if in my opinion do i think that
walker or thibodeau will go first i will
tell you my opinion on march 8th is that
trayvon walker will get picked ahead of
kayvon thibodeau
okay
all right
um the news uh of the day daniel uh i
don't know if you heard it because it
was just uh recently announced aaron
rodgers is staying put in green bay four
years 200 million dollars your thoughts
on that subject
wow yeah well
yeah yeah you i haven't seen that so i
guess what happens you drop the kids off
at school you missed the biggest nfl
news of the season here um that's well
it's kind of what we originally thought
um i think after the season ended and
you heard aaron's you know positivity
towards everyone in the organization
both you know downstairs and upstairs
that uh it looked like it was headed
towards that and
uh you know then i think there's that
delay so we sat there and entertained
the idea of maybe this is this could
this could happen he could go somewhere
else but we were sitting up there in the
booth talking about this rich and just i
couldn't imagine
i couldn't imagine him playing for
anybody else i couldn't imagine as a
general manager wanting it on your
resume that you traded the reigning
two-time mvp
so i think this is the most logical uh
move for for aaron and uh man i'm
excited for the packers fans because you
look at the nfc
um depending on whether uh our next
topic of conversation which after this
i'm sure we're gonna hit if that
gentleman were to stay away the the
runway is pretty clear there uh in the
nfc i know you've got the defending
super bowl champs and the rams
but the packers are right there at the
top the 153 million of the 200 is
guaranteed daniel and this is just a
remarkable
moment
certainly
where we were aft the night of the 2020
draft when the packers traded up to get
jordan love and
rogers correctly assumed as everyone
else assumed that 2022 would be the
absolute come hecker high water moment
to which
at which the packers would turn to
jordan love so they could actually see
what they have in him right and that's
why rogers gave them a freebie year of
the 2020 season and then really push
came to shove for 2021 for him to come
back and then he came up in both of
those seasons with mvp campaigns and
here we are with them now saying
i guess we'll just see jordan love in
another spot because that money means
love will have to go through his entire
rookie contract without getting on the
field it seems
and um or
unless of an injury or as we saw with
rogers with covid what what do you think
about what happens with jordan love now
i i would imagine he's somewhere else
sooner than later you know there's a lot
of there's a lot of teams looking for
quarterbacks right now
um
i i don't see what the purpose would be
really to bring him back um aaron's
proven to be very durable
um and there's you know the value i
think with jordan the longer he goes
without playing is probably going to go
down so i would think this is the uh
this is the off season and probably in
the very very near future that you'll
see a move made there but they're not
going to get anywhere close to what they
they used to acquire him yeah right but
i mean he's going to be a he's going to
be kind of hopefully look hopefully
jordan loves goes somewhere gets
opportunity to play and ends up having a
long productive career as a starting
quarterback if not he's going to be one
of the more fascinating footnotes in nfl
history that um i would say he
he lit a fire under aaron rodgers and
produced some of the best quarterback
play we've ever seen in the history of
this league
right so
and his one game taking on the chiefs
daniel
um
did that
affect anything do you think or or what
like what can you how can you evaluate
jordan love at this point in time if you
are thinking you know what let's let's
give this kid a whirl like we loved him
coming out of the giraffe packers left
in front of us to go get him and so on
and so forth those are stories that
could be told or maybe even accurate
what do you think
what do you think well i don't think
he's i don't think you saw enough in
that that brief exposure to get super
excited about him um
so he came in he came into the league
as a maybe not great phrasing there no
no no that's one way by the way you
sound like chris greer when asked about
tua can he be you know a a top notch or
elite quarterback and i can't say he
can't you know what i mean like that's
what that sounded like to me from chris
greer last week you know yeah
no i i i
i would say if you're asking me right
now what the market would be for jordan
love yeah you probably hoping you could
get a third round pick that would be
that would be probably your hope
so um before i let you go then what what
does the the quarterback class look like
now coming out of the combine do you
think in the draft
daniel i i think i think teams are all
over the map in in terms of the order i
think there's some uh you know i thought
desmond ritter really helped himself um
you know i thought that uh malik willis
was what we thought he's got a huge arm
um you know we'll get a chance to see
him move around and run you'll see how
athletic he is once he gets to his pro
day which he's off the charts there but
still a project and i thought kenny
pickett to me entered as the top guy um
and had a really solid workout that's
that's uh you know that's kind of who he
is and i think you could if if you miss
out on these veterans i would think
kenny pickett would kind of be the the
guy that you could hope could come in
and play right away uh the rest of this
group i think you're probably looking
more of a developmental route so they're
gonna some of them you know at least one
of them maybe two or three will find
their way into the first round they'll
force their way in there rich but i i
don't think we see one go in the top ten
this year i really don't so then who who
goes and gets them right like who goes
and drafts these guys now that we again
we know rogers is staying put
um
russell wilson is the the the we have no
interest is what pete carroll said in
trading them washington commanders are
apparently going yolo knocking on
everybody's door trying to see if any
they can get anybody
and and the seahawks reportedly
rebuffed them
so um you also think kylo murray is
going nowhere too right that's your
opinion on that
correct i think the big name veterans
are are staying put uh you know except
for the whole uh situation with deshaun
watson how that how that plays out is to
be determined but uh yeah i think this
is gonna cause teams to
um i think you might even mention it on
the show yesterday rich that like guys
like mitchell trubisky
they love the fact that the carousel has
not started spinning because now there
are there's simply more more seats than
options available which is going to
really help his market yeah right so um
okay so what do you think then who's
gonna
what's your best guess and again we'll
have you back on and won't hold any
won't hold you to it your best guess who
when it's all said and done
they're like you know what we're not
going to go in the free agent market for
trubisky we're not going to go try and
acquire somebody coming off of surgery
like garoppolo or
uh winston you know through free agency
i mean who do you think does go
certainly the colts are in a fascinating
position you know we had frank reich
sitting there and
it didn't sound like wentz is going back
there after he left the booth with us
daniel so who do you think in the draft
is going to
maybe use a first rounder and say this
is this is worth the risk right now what
do you think
well i think the the uh
the team that's fascinating to me is
this is uh the team
that's picking there at the very bottom
of the of the first round they're also
picking at the with the second pick in
the first round that's the detroit lions
like this feels like a draft to me where
it's um you know we can use our high
seconds to try and get back up into the
first or in the lions case they happen
to have already have the 30 overall pick
they get their their cornerstone key
player with their their first selection
they come back and take a flyer out of
malik willis or desmond ritter or
somebody like that uh at the bottom or
at the top or the bottom of the first
round for them and then some of these
other teams
that might be in the market maybe they
try and slide back into the back of one
um to get guys so
that would be something to keep an eye
on i think denver i think the broncos
pick 40 somewhere around there in the
second round right you know that could
be a situation where hey you maybe try
to come up with 31 to get that extra
year on the contract and take a flyer on
uh you know on kenny pickett if it's him
or sam howell whichever whichever flavor
you like there certainly since um the
whole idea that uh rogers was coming
there because he was going to leave
green bay is that is now history how
about that man
how about what i mean
i feel bad for drew lock can you imagine
just the disappointment as a broncos fan
i mean
you thought for a second you gave
yourself a glimmer of hope that the envy
reigning mvp still in his prime was
gonna be your quarterback no pressure
drew all right and then i guess one last
one uh just to circle back daniel before
i let you go
kyler murray why do you think he's not
going anywhere how do you how do you
come up with that based on
everything uh coming out of the combine
and certainly going into it why do you
think that well i think
i think kyler's definitely frustrated
wants a new deal
i think they're going to try and exert
some leverage and if they don't get a
new deal i anticipate they're probably
going to ask to be traded
and there's absolutely no reason for the
arizona cardinals to do that and however
frustrated you are with the way his play
may be tailed off the last two years
he's extremely gifted and you have no
shot of upgrading that position so
that's the case he's got really no
leverage you can say baseball but i
think they'll call that bluff there's no
way that's gonna happen
so i just don't see any situation where
you you would move on from a guy like
that i don't see it happening he's going
to be their quarterback well as always i
guess you're right look to the gram all
of his pictures are apparently back on
his instagram
so really yes he archived him he
archived him he didn't delete he
archived them or there's some uh
unfortunate
k1 intern who had to throw them all back
on there um so
uh they're back what level of what level
of player do you have to be that people
would notice that by the way like
where's the cut off line like you're
you're just kind of like a number two
tight end for the team and you scrub all
the mentions of the of the team and you
go like two weeks like man nobody's even
nobody even picked up on you yeah
unfortunately every new york jet has
gotten off of instagram and we haven't
noticed it every you know what i mean
[Laughter]
there you go so what are you saying
thanks for the call daniel you're the
best brother thanks again see you buddy
everyone check out the move the sticks
podcast certainly coming off of the
combine he and bucky brooks doing that
today
right here on the rich eisen shoe
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here